on the South Kona Coast of Hawaii Island
there is one of the last Hawaiian
fishing villages in the world and it's
okay
[Music]
it's still practice traditional fishing
in the old stuff you know canoe chumming
the water the way that generations of
points have done
it is something that needs to be
experienced first time if we don't
continue to learn these things that
knowledge will be lost
why is Marco Gucci my friends call me
Gooch and I'm a chef here in Hawaii
my belief is and preserving the
techniques in degrees that we have in
this place that I call when we talk
about Hawaiian food
there's before Western context that is
post what's your contact one of the
biggest misconceptions about Hawaiian
food is how it's always presented in
this gigantic you know luau with the EMU
and the kalua pig and then the fire
knife dancer which that's not even how I
am Hawaiians date simply it was largely
a very ocean or pellew and vegetable
based diet the reason why I'm going down
to Falconer today is to spend the day
with one of the Hawaiian families who
have graciously called their friends and
family to come down and share their
practice Hawaiian practices around
fishing and planting and growing oil is
all about sustainability we fish with
nets and catch what we need
Oh pillow is a mackerel and it's the
mainstay of a fishing village head if
you were to try and go in the water and
catch them with a spear or something
else they're gonna just leave they're
not gonna stay around you need to feed
them you would prepare their bait which
was 100% vegetable we call that the
hollow that's put into a bag and the bag
is thrown into the ocean and when it's
yanked all the Paolo of the bait is let
go the fish aggregate and come around
and feed we don't separate ourselves
from the light we don't separate
ourselves from what feeds us so it was
important them to sustain those
aggregation areas and they did that by
feeding the fish during the off season
without even catching them and this
would this is a means to train the fish
to come back to the same area all the
time it's almost like ocean farming so
after you harvest of this fish you got
to clean it and you see a tease and you
see husbands and you see friends come
around everybody knows that there's a
job to do today we're going to prepare a
fellow in as many ways as possible
[Music]
fried seasoned just with Paul Kai
keeping it super simple we're also gonna
have a blue bra which is just caught up
and it's just lightly seasoned oppa do
la me where you taking any and you'll
owe me you turn it and you mix it with
other ingredients onions tomatoes and
green onions season with like just chili
pepper and salt we also have pointed a
fresh point boy is towel has been cooked
and it's been mixed with water and it is
one of our staple starches we also have
which is breadfruit breadfruit is
another traditional mine staple as well
so this is how we eat every day simple
one thing that we always do we bless the
food it's a non-denominational all order
hands and all the spirits and all the
people that have come together put all
this food together mala and then you eat
you just sit around and hang out that's
when the stories come on that's
everything that we've worked for for
that day it reinforces for myself the
importance of being able to know the
difference of what it is that we're
cooking a serving
[Music]
in today's day and age where we are all
worried about our resources there people
still doing their part to preserve an
ecosystem it lends hope for us to
continue to preserve the place that we
call home we need to take these lessons
and then aren't shared worldwide we need
to be able to take these lessons and
apply them to our daily life
[Music]
you
[Music]